بريطانيا تكتب وجودها الدبلوماسيه لحجز
الدعم لكييف وصفارته الانذار تنطلق ليلا
في معظم انحي اوكرانيا
احتجاجا على نقص الوقود بالتزامن مع موجه
برد غير مصنوقه
وفي تحول تاريخيا الصين تسجل تراجعا في
عدد السكان للمره الاولى منذ 60 عاما
والهند تنافسها على المرتبه الاولى
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل الخير واهلا بكم الى
فتره اخباريه جديده من العربيه نبداها
بهذه النشره دون سفارات الانذار لتحديد من
الغارات الجويه في عده مناطق شرق اوكرانيا
حسب خريطه التحذير من الغارات الجويه
الصادره عن وزاره التحول الرقمي
الاوكرانيه كما دواء السفاره الانذار
لتحديد من الغارات الجويه في الجزء الذي
تسيطر عليه ثياب من منطقه زبرجيا
هذا واكد رئيس
الاوكرانيسكي ان الهجوم الاخير على ديني
برو يظهروا حاجه بلاده الماسه لقرارات
سريعه من الشركاء الدوليين لتزويدها
بالاسلحه الجديده والمتطوره
القتال على الجبهه تتطلب امدادات دفاعيه
جديده بالتالي هنا تكمن اهميه التنسيق بين
جهودنا وجهود جميع اعضاء التحالف للدفاع
عن اوكرانيا وحريتها
كما دعا رئيس الاوكرانيه منظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا لبذل المزيد من الجهد
لاعاده الاوكرانيين الذين نقلتهم من قوات
الروسيه قصرا الى روسيا ولفت زيلسكي خلال
لقاء جمعه برئيس منظمه الامن والتعاون
بجوار عثماني الى انه لم تتمكن اي منظمه
دوليه حتى الان من الوصول الى اماكن
احتجاج السجناء الاوكرانيين في روسيا
هذا وسيسعى وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس
كليبرري الى تعزيز الدعم لاوكرانيا في
رحله الى الولايات المتحده وكندا تبدا
اليوم الثلاثاء وقالت ليفر لي في بيان ان
الغربه متحد ضد حرب بوتين غير الشرعيه وان
بلاده ستواصل واستخدام علاقتها الدفاعيه
والامنيه لضمان فوز الشعب الاوكراني
بعد انظمه صواريخ بعيده المدى ومدرعات
وانظمه دفاع جوي ارضي دبابات تشارجر اثنين
البريطانيه الصنع في طريقها الى القوات
الاوكرانيه في احدث دعم عسكري لكيف للتصدي
للعمليات العسكريه الروسيه المستمره هذا
ما اعلنه رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
واكده وزير الدفاع
الان لتسريع النجاح الاوكراني تشمل سربا
من دبابات تشالنجر
بمركبات الاسترداد واصلاح المدرعات وسوف
نتبرع بالسلاح المدفعين مضره لاوكرانيا
بنادق عاليه الدقه واسلحه المدفعيه اخرى
في مراحل مختلفه من الجاهزيه
هذه الحزمه العسكريه الجديده من بريطانيا
الى اوكرانيا حظيت بتاييد واسع من مختلف
الاحزاب السياسيه للوقوف في وجه الرئيس
بوتن الذي اخطا في تقدير حملته العسكريه
ولوقوف الدول الغربيه في صف واحد بجانب
الرئيس الاوكراني لحمايه اراضي بلاده كما
تقول لندن تعمل كيف ان يمهد القرار
البريطاني ارسال الحلفاء اسلحه ومعدات
عسكريه ثقيله متطوره للقوات الاوكرانيه
كانت قبل اشهر فقط من المحرمات لتفادي
تصعيدي روسيا الحرب
اوكرانيا اقنعت حلفائها البريطانيين
والفرنسيين والبولنديين تدريجيا لارسال
اسلحه النوعيه تحدث فارقا على ارض
الاقتتال ما سيزيد الضغط على برلين لتسليم
الدبابات قتاليه حديثه من نوع لابد اثنين
الى استخدام دباباتها يجب ان تكون في
اوكرانيا للقتال على الارض وينطبق الشيء
نفسه على كل دوله لا تزال تمتلك اسلحه في
المخازن ولا تمنحها لاوكرانيا واحد اكبر
التهديدات للامن في العالم هو روسيا
والبلد الوحيد القادر على ايقاف روسيا هو
اوكرانيا
بريطانيا التي تعتبر ثانيه اكبر المانحين
لاوكرانيا بعد الولايات المتحده سيحث رئيس
وزراءها ريس هناك الشركاء الغربيين على
تسريع الدعم لاوكرانيا مع اقتراب مرور عام
على الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وروسيا في
موقف ضعيف في ساحه المعركه بسبب مشاكل
الامداد والتدهور روحي معنويه جنودها
مصطفى زاروه العربيه
لندن
[موسيقى]
عبر رئيسه الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الدريه
رافاييل روسيا خلال زيارته السادسه
لاوكرانيا عن امله في احراز تقدم بشان
اتفاقا لاقامه منطقه امنه حول منطقه ومحطه
زابارجي النوويه لكنه شدد على انها ستكون
مفاوضه صعبه واوضح جروسي ان الوضع في محيط
المحطه لا يزال خطيرا للغايه معتبرا انه
وقوع اي حادث نووي ستكون له عواقب اشعاعيه
خطيره لا تصب في مصلحه احد
الى ايران واحتجاجا على انقطاع الغاز
اقتحم محتاجين ايرانيون مقر الهلال الاحمر
في بلده قريبه واقعه شمال شرق البلاد وفقا
لما افادت به وسائل الاعلام المحليه
واضافت ان المحتاجين اغلق الشوارع باشعال
النار بعد تجمعهم امام مبنى المدينه وصله
مناهضه للنظام كما نقلت عن المتظاهرين
قولهم ان اسعار اجهزه التدفئه ارتفعت بشكل
حاد بتزامني مع انقطاع الغاز
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات متواصله في وجه مراوغات سياسيه
والتفاف على مطالب تحرر المجتمع الايراني
اربعه اشهر على انتفاضه ايران كانت كافيه
لكشف عوار النظام وقرارات سياسيه في اتجاه
وممارسات في اتجاه اخر فبحسب صحيفه
النظام لفرد عقوبات على النساء التي
يخالفن معايير ارتداء الحجاب ليستبدل
الاعتقال بفرض عقوبات قد تصل الى حضر
السفر الدولي ودفع غرامات ماليه
مكتب المدعي العام الايرانيه اصدر توجيهات
جديده للشرطه بالامتناع عن اعتقال النساء
اللائي يخالفن قواعد اللباس النسائيه في
البلاد ولكن بدلا من ذلك فرض عقوبات عليهم
الى استخدام كاميرات المراقبه الامنيه
الكاميرات المستخدمه لتسجيل المخالفات
المروريه يمكنها تنفيذ هذا العمل بشكل
منهجي لمراقبه النساء اللائي يخالفن قواعد
اللباسه وتجنب اصطدام مباشر اخر بين
الشرطه والمواطنين اذا لم تمر سوى بضعه
ايام على حل شرطه الاخلاق من قبل المدعي
العام الايراني غياب العناصرها في الشوارع
وحضور لكاميرات مراقبه النساء الى جانب
رسائل التهديد على هواتفهن المحموله اما
الوصايه او فرد مزيد من العقوبات
علي السمان العربيه
هذا ووصف وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس
كليبر لاعدام النظام الايراني علي اكبر
صالحي بالانتقام السياسي وقال ان بريطانيا
تقف الى جانب الشعب الايراني الذي يطالب
بحقوقه وحريته امام سياسه القمع الوحشي
التي يتبعها نظام ايران
قبل موته شرح السيد اكبر ما حدث له
والتعذيب الذي تعرض له بدون شك لقد كان
ضحيه للانتقام السياسي النظام
الوحشيلا لقياده لا تتورع عن استخدام اداه
سياسيا لاسكات الانتقادات وتصفيه الحسابات
اعدام السيد اكبارياتي بعد عقود من القمع
الوحشي من قبل نظام قاسم بريطانيا تقف الى
جانب الشعب الايراني الشجاع الذي يطالب
بحقوقه وحريته هذه الشجاعه تظهر من خلال
الواقع المؤلم بان اكثر من 500 شخص قتلوا
ثمانيه عشر الف اخرين اعتقلوا خلال الموجه
الاخيره من الاحتجاجات
يقوم وزير الخارج
بزياره الى تركيا اليوم حيث يلتقي بعدد من
كبار المسؤولين لمناقشه الوضع في سوريا
وكذلك المفاوضات الاخيره بين وزراء الدفاع
الروسي والسوري والتركي وقالت مصادر ان
زياره عبد الله هيان تاتي استكمالا لما
بداه في دمشق بعد لقائه برئيس النظام
السوري بشار الاسد ووزير خارجيه فيصل
المقداد وتصدق زياره عبد الله الى انقره
زياره المرتقبه لنظيره التركي شاويش اوغلو
الى واشنطن يطلع خلالها المسؤولين
الامريكيين على مسار التقارب بين دمشق
وانقره في ظل رفض امريكي لهذا تقارب
ونبقى معكم في سياق هذه النشره ولدينا
المؤسسه الملكيه البريطانيه تحاول ترتيبا
مصالحه بين هاري والعائله
نوصل وما حضراتكم تقديم هذه النشره استقبل
رئيس مجلس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني منسق البيت الابيض لشؤون الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا برقمه جورج مبعوثا
من الرئيس الامريكي من جانبه اكد ماتورك
ادعما بلده لانجاح الحكومه العراقيه
الحاليه واستمرار الولايات المتحده في
تقديم المشهوره للقوات العراقيه في قتلها
ضد داعش
كشفت قناه العربيه تفاصيل الشماع القاهره
الذي جمع اطراف الليبيه حيث طلب قائد
الجيش خليفه حفتر بضروره توحيد المؤسسه
العسكريه واتمت مناقشته دمج عناصر
المليشيا المسلحه في الجيش بشكل تدريجي
فيما اتفق المشاركون في الاجتماع على
ابعاد المتطرفين وذوي الاحكام الجنائيه
كما اكدوا على ضروره وجود حكومه موحده
وحياديه تقود الانتخابات وتكون مدعومه
شعبيه وليس حكومتين
وطرحت المبادره ايضا نقطه مهمه تتعلق
بضروره وقف العمل بالاتفاقيات التي
ابرمتها حكومه الديبه وطرحها للاستفتاء
الشعبي فيما بعد كما تمت مناقشته وقف في
اي اتفاقيات تم ابراها حاليا لمنع حدوث في
ازمه في ليبيا
في السودان اثار قرار المحكمه باذنه زوجه
رئيس المعزول عمر البشير وداد بابكر بتهمه
الثراء المشبوه ردود افعال واسعه في ما
اعتبر جزء من الشارع السوداني القراره
خطوه لتحقيق العداله
على زوجها من قبل بحيازه النقد الاجنبي
واليوم هي المتهمه بتهمه الثراء الحرام
والمشوه داخل محكمه جرائم الفساد ومخالفات
المال العام بالخرطوم وبعد ثلاث سنوات من
المداولات على وداد بابكر زوجه الرئيس
المعزول عمر البشير قضيت المحكمه بمصادره
عقارات واراضي زراعيه ومشغوله ذهبيه ورغم
ضخامه الغرامه التي تقدر ب 100 مليون جنيه
لصالح حكومه السودان الا ان العقوبه مخففه
بنظره قانونيين لم تتم محاكمتها بموجب
قانون ازاله تمكين او قانون يعني التغيير
الاجتماعي
على الجانب الاخر يرى المدافعون عن وداد
بابكر ان المحكمه شابتها مخالفات وانهم
ماضون في استئناف القرار الان القرار من
المحكمه اليوم صدر كل ممتلكات ابناء على
الرغم من انه ابناء برده مواجعين باتهام
وفصل البلاغ في مواجهتهم او فصول الالتهاب
في مواجهات الممارسه المحليه من يقدم
مواطنون ان الاجراء هو الطريق الصحيح
لاسترداد اموال الدوله المنهوبه عبر
القضاء لارسال العداله
دائما لانه صورتنا
صوره امنيه على ثلاثه اجزاء
حريه سلام عداله
في اموال مهربه
السوداني يجيب لنا الحياه
تضعوا المواطن السوداني مراقبه
في تحقيق العداله وخوفين من ضياع حقه لين
يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اشاد رئيس
الوزراء الباكستانيه شهبا الشريف بالقياده
الدنماركيه لولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان مؤكدا ان تلك القياده جعلت
المجتمع السعودي اكثر ازدهرا
رساله
العربيه المتحده تحت قياده الشيخ محمد بن
زايد الرمال الى ذهب وكيف اصبح المجتمع
السعودي من اكثر الشعوب العالميه ازدهار
تحت هذه القياده الديناميكيه لاخي صاحب
السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان
وفي شان اخر قال شهد الشريف ان بلاده تريد
العيش بسلام مع الهند بشرط حل المشكلات
الاساسيه وقال شريف ان باكستان والهند
خاضتها ثلاث حروب وكانت النتيجه البنزيده
من البطاله والفقر
علينا اتخاذ القرار لقد تعلمت باكستان
الدرس
حروب مع الهند وعواقب تلك الحروب
الهنديه ورئيس الوزراء مودي
لنجلس والله خذ محادثات جده وصادقه لحل
مسائلنا الملحه مثل كشمير التي تشهد
انتهاكات صارخه لحقوق الانسان في كل يوم
في افغانستان خلف قرار وطالبان الاخير
بمنع النساء من العمل في المنظمات المحليه
والدوليه مشكلات وصعوبات كبيره للمراه
الافغانيه العربيه التقت طبيباتن وعاملات
في المجال الصحي الزمهن القرار البقاء في
منازلهن يواجهنا شبح الفقر بعد ان فقدنا
مصدر رزقهن الوحيد
[موسيقى]
كانت طبيبه في احدى المنظمات الدوليه وقد
تعطلت عن العمل جراء الفرمان الجديد
لطالبان بمنع السيدات من العمل في
المنظمات الدوليه والمحليه تقول ان راتبها
كان المصدر الوحيد لعائلتها واطفالها
السته
التزمت المنزل بعد ما اعلن الطالبان انها
لا تسمح لنا بالعمل زوج عاطل عن العمل
وضعنا الاقتصادي ضعيف نعيش حياه صعبه في
منزل باجره
بهار هي الاخرى كانت عامله في المجال
الصحي في احدى المنظمات وقد تعطلت عن
العمل ايضا وابوها قد توفي منذ زمن وهي
المعينه الوحيده لعائلتها التي تعيش في
وضع اقتصادي صعب كما تقول
والمنظمات بدورها قامت بتسريح فيها
وبالتالي لم استطع الاستمرار في العمل
يقول عدد من الطبيبات والعاملات في مجال
الصحه ان القيود المختلفه التي فرضتها
طالبان على النساء الافغانيات قد اضرت بهن
كثيرا بحسب الطبيبات والعاملات في مجال
الصحه فان القرار بمنع السيدات من العمل
في المنظمات قد خلق مخاطر قاتله لملايين
النساء والاطفال الذين يحتاجون الى عمل
الطبيبات
العربيه كابول
[موسيقى]
تصرع مؤسسه الملكيه البريطانيه الى احتواء
ازمه عائله مع الامير هاري بعد كشفه عن
تفاصيل محرجه عن افراد العائله
واخلافاتها في كتابه الى جانب عده مقابله
تلفزيونيه اجراها تسويقا للكتاب
بعد قرابه الشهر على دراما العائله
الملكيه وخلافاتها تتجه الامطار نحو معضله
جديده معضله دعوه الامير هاري الى حفل
تنصيب والده اسئله كثيره تراود المؤسسه
الملكيه هل تتم دعوته هل يتم اعطائه فرصه
جديده في الاجتماعات العائليه والسؤال
الاهم من سيكون مسؤولا عن ابلاغه بعدم
حضور الحفل
اجوبه تسارع المؤسسه الملكيه الى ايجاد
صيغه لحسمها قبل ثلاثه اشهر على حفل تتويج
الملك تشارلز وهو ما يبدو انه اثار عده
سيناريوهات يتم بحثها حاليا اولا مصالحه
محتمله بين الامير هاري وعائلته كالخيال
الافضل للمضي قدما والاسرع وقتا لتجنب
المزيد من الاحراج واشارت مصادر مطلعه من
القصر الى ان اجتماعا في طور التحضير بين
هاري والملك وولي عهده
الامر
يريد المصالح بعد طعنه في الظهر
كما تتم مناقشه خطه بديله في حال فشل
المصالحه تكمن في عدم دعوى هاري لحضور حفل
تنصيب وتدرس المؤسسه في هذا الصدد نقل
مسؤوليتي ابلاغ هاري بعدم دعوته من يد
الملك تشارلز الى يد رئيس الوزراء ريشي
سوناك الذي يحق له بهذه الحاله اتخذه موقف
منهاري باعتبار انه لا يملك لقبا ملكيا
وان حفله تنصيب هو مناسبه تخص الدوله
تحقيق المصالحه بين هاري وعائلته يكمل في
استعداد الطرفين لوضع خلافته ما جانبا
وربما الاهم على قدره هذه لتخلي عن هجومه
ضد عائلته التي عاده ما تتبع شعار لا تشرح
لا تتدمر ولكن هل ينجح هاري في دفع عائلته
الى التخلي عن شعارها والتصعيد ضد الضغط
العربي العربيه
ما في تطور تاريخيا تراجع عدد سكان الصين
في العالم العام الماضي للمره الاولى منذ
نحو سته عقود وافقا لما اظهرت بيانات
الرسميه وافاد المكتب الصيني الوطني
للاحصاء انه بحلول نهايه عام 2022 بلغ عدد
السكان نحو مليار و 401 10 مليون نسمه
مضيفا انه سجل انخفاضا بلغات 850,000 نسمه
مقارنه بنهايه عام 20 21 واذا استمر الوضع
على هذه الوتيره فان الهند في طريقها الى
منافسه الصين على المرتبه الاولى في عدد
السكان بالعالم
قال حاكم ولايه كاليفورنيا الامريكيه ان
العواصف المتعقبه التي اجتاحت الولايه
تسببت بمقتل 20 شخصا على الاقل فيما تحولت
شوارع صندايكو الى بحيرات وانهار جراء
الفيضانات والامطار الغزيره
الى العناوين
بريطانيا تكتب وجودها دبلوماسيه لحج الدعم
لكيا مواصفات
ليلا في معظم انحي اوكرانيا
احتجاجا على نقص الوقود بالتزامني مع موجه
برد غير مسبوقه
في تحول تاريخي الصين في عدد السكان للمره
الاولى منذ 60 عاما والهند تنافسها على
المرتبه الاولى
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]